so almost immediately after Nikki
Haley's announcement that she's running
for president through the Republican
nomination in 2024 the Trump campaign
put out a confusing and bizarre campaign
email attacking Nikki Haley and what's
really fascinating about this email
which we'll look at in a moment is it
attacks Nikki Haley for being too much
of a leftist but also for being too
extreme on the right it is as confusing
as and bizarre as everything we have
come to expect and see from the Trump
campaign take a look at this so the
first lines are first it's called the
real Nikki Haley first of all Trump's
going to tell you who the real Nikki
Haley is okay it starts by saying
Hillary Clinton is an inspiration to
Nikki Haley in a 2012 interview with the
New York Times Nikki Haley said the
reason I actually ran for office is
because of Hillary Clinton so here it
wants to tag Nikki Haley it wants to
trash Nikki Haley by saying she's really
not a conservative because she was
inspired by Hillary Clinton of course it
ignores the uncontroversial reality
that you could disagree with Hillary
Clinton's politics but see Hillary
Clinton's success as an elected official
and public servant as someone who is a
woman as inspirational that's not super
controversial but she's not really on
the right she's on the left because she
was inspired by Hillary and then in the
next sentence Trump slams Nikki Haley
for supporting Paul Ryan's plan for
entitlement reform which threatened
Medicare and Social Security
saying quote Haley praised Ryan's
Medicare proposal at the time and said
lawmakers should examine Medicare and
Social Security spending to address
federal debt then quoting Nikki Haley
herself from 2010 saying what they need
to be doing is looking at entitlements
look at Social Security look at Medicaid
look at Medicare look at these things
let's go to the heart of what is causing
government to grow and tackle that
they're playing that Nikki Haley is too
extreme in what she wants to cut and in
the government spending she wants to
reduce which is normally an attack that
the left makes on the right so Haley's a
leftist and Haley is too far right it's
not coherent but in the defense of trump
Haley's campaign isn't very coherent so
far and Trump's attacks on her are also
not coherent but Nikki Haley at some
point might want to articulate what
policy is she actually running on now I
say she might want to articulate it
because as I said earlier in the program
it's not clear that she needs any policy
in order to win a Republican primary
Trump had some policy statements in
2016. most of them we all knew were
never going to be achieved he wasn't
going to replace Obamacare and he wasn't
going to build a wall that Mexico was
going to pay for and he wasn't going to
do all the things he claimed it didn't
really matter it's not clear that these
Republicans care about policy enough to
hold it against Nikki Haley but at a
certain point you'll have to come up
with something that at least she can put
on her website and that hasn't happened
yet it's all incoherent and this is
exactly what I would expect much more of
in this Republican primary
you know I have a very acute Newfound
appreciation for how busy being a new
parent makes you if you have a little
one at home like me here's something
really easy you can do to simplify your
life our sponsor little spoon is your
One-Stop shop for healthy easy meal time
and snack time for your baby toddler or
big kid delivered right to your door
little spoon delivers fresh organic baby
food which comes in single ingredient
varieties or multi-textured purees
little spoon is meals for toddlers and
big kids they're free of junk and taste
great even the pickiest eaters love them
I've even tried many of them myself they
really are great having healthy snack
time is so easy with little spoons
organic smoothies which come in
convenient pouches in great flavors like
strawberry banana shake purple carrot
acai I love purple carrots I'm gonna
admit that my girlfriend and I have had
a great experience with our little spoon
subscription it just makes life easier
anything to reduce the chaos is a great
thing little spoon is giving my audience
50 off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use code Pacman 50
off all one word the info is down below